لانه احنا سالنا الناس في الشارع الاردني
شو هو الاصح برايكم انه تاكلوا متى تشاءون
او ما تشاؤون خلينا نشوف يلا
[موسيقى]
بسرعه بفضل اكل شو ما بدي لانه احيانا
فرصه انك تاكل اكل انت ما عمرك جربتها ومش
من بلدك او اشي غالي مثلا بفضل اكل شو ما
بدي
لانه بكون عندك دائما خيارات كثيره والاكل
خيارات واسع جدا فبتخيل بحب اختار ايش بحب
اكل وقت ما بدي لانه لانه بحس انه جسمي
طالب انه اكل بهذا الوقت
[موسيقى]
بفضل اكل شو ما بدي
يعني انا شو ما بدي انا اللي باكله لانه
مش شوي بيكي بالاكل فبختار الاكلات اللي
انا بحبها اللي انا بتناسبني وعلى مزاجي
تفضل اكل وقت ما بدي بس يكون برضه كمان زي
ما بدي يعني بنفس الوقت الوقت مهم ولكن
كتير مهم يعني
الجانبين كثير مهمات وقت ما بدي شو ما بدي
لانه اغلب وقت جوعان فاي بلاقيه قدامي
يعني اي شيء بسكر المعده
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات